what do you think about an actor
investing their own money in a project
you think that's a good idea do you
think it's it's risky to invest your own
money in a project but Angeline rolls
Troy did it she funded the sin of dope
seat season and it's amazing thing she
had the idea that she owned the property
of this movie theater comedy and she
wanted to make it and she wanted to do a
comedy in an ensemble and hire other
actors and give us all a chance to do a
really cool show and I something that
I've rarely done invest my own money in
my own projects invested in other
people's projects but not often in my
own because I always feel like I'm Mardi
bringing enough the table when I do my
own thing and I want somebody else to
share the risk with me and so there's
more of a team that is invested but
Angeline really believed and it wanted
to put her own money in it and God bless
her for doing it because when a bad will
do it otherwise so there would be no sin
of dopes without her so it's amazing
thing that she did it and I hope that we
gain enough to an audience that she
doesn't regret doing it because it's a
funny show and she's funny in it and the
cast is great and we all worked really
hard on it so it only get better season
two so when you said you've invested in
other projects not your own or not once
that you are featured in what are some
of the key items what is your like due
diligence that you're you know you're
checking up okay all right all right you
know I'll do this what are some of the
things that you look for in those
projects they might you know I have an
invested a ton a phrase on where we
haven't invested son of my own money and
other comedic projects i'm currently
perusing whether or not i'm going to
invest in stand-up comedy specials
producing specials for other comedians I
just shot mine and didn't do it under my
own banners I know I want the validation
of another production company saying
that they want me and I want to be able
to do that same thing for somebody else
but it's more investing time of helping
somebody taking comics under your wing
bringing comics on the road that you
think of talent and bringing them out
and helping you know if they just giving
them stage time or any advice if they
wanted it about ways to you know develop
material that might suit them better to
help them you know long to create stuff
that might be more of a of a solid AG
that can help take them further in the
stand up
world what it is in people that what out
what is I look for it's just talent you
know I think you obviously can't be a
total fuck-up and have no work ethic but
you can learn a work ethic you can't
really learn talent so I just I just
feel like I've always had a pretty good
I you know I'd finding talent and
knowing when people are good you know
throughout my career I've given untold
thousands of comedy spots to all the up
and coming comedians that people love
now I helped a lot of them you know with
their first spots and major clubs I've
got them into the improv until the
comedy juice shows and help get them
seen by agents and producers and leading
to big things for them and I just only
book talent and it's hard to do that
because I don't envy casting directors
have to do that or producers have to
decide who invest in because you're
putting a lot of money and a lot of your
career and life on the line to invest in
people and so you have to you just have
to pass on people that aren't talented
you have to pass on people who don't
have it and the sad version of that is
when people work really really hard
don't have talent that's unfortunate
even but each some work hard working
hard can help can be so affected you and
sometimes they make it through often
times but when someone doesn't have
talent and no organic it's easy to pass
on it's like why why care they don't
even care so I just look for a spark of
you look for people that are delivering
it well delivering a joke that hits
delivering a content-based content a
short film a painting you're like pow
that looks like it has skill and
uniqueness to it that's what you look
for who were some of the first people
you made life wasn't someone in your
family was a kid at school yeah I'm sure
it's my family I made laugh since I was
a kid my parents my brother my
grandparents and then at school all the
time you know even with my speech
problem i was still on and off able to
speak better different parts of the year
different classes right from work on
flights still one class comedian in
sixth seventh and eighth grade even
though i had a speech problem throughout
all that because i was just still able
to like find funny ways to talk and to
say things into
point out absurdities in other people's
behavior and did that a very stammered a
weird way often times but it was always
fun making people laugh at school comedy
is a really interesting defuser of
tension it's a really interesting
icebreaker it's a really great way to
you know lubricate a room
you